in this video i want to talk a little
bit about newton's first law of motion
and this is a translation from newton's
principia from latin into english so the
first law everybody persists in a state
of being at rest so state of being at
rest or moving uniformly straight
forward except in so far as it is
compelled to change its state by force
impressed so another way to rephrase
what they're saying is that if there's
something
everybody persists so everything will
stay at rest or moving with a constant
velocity unless it is compelled to
change its state by force unless it's
acted on by a force especially an
unbalanced force and i'll explain that
in a second so if i have something
that's at rest so completely at rest so
i have a
i have
this is something that we've seen before
let's say that i have a
i would say that i have a rock
let's say that i have a rock someplace
i have a rock someplace and it's laying
on a field of grass
on a field of grass i can keep observing
that rock and it is unlikely to move
assuming that nothing happens to it if
there's no force applied to that rock
that rock will just stay there so the
first part is pretty obvious if a body
so everybody persists in a state of
being at rest
i'm not going to do the second part
except in so far there's some force
being applied to it so clearly a rock
will be at rest unless there's some
force applied to it unless someone here
tries to push it or or roll it or do
something to it what's less intuitive
about the first law is the second part
everybody persist in either being in a
state of rest or moving uniformly
straight forward except in so far as it
is compelled to change its state by
force impressed so this newton's first
law and i i think i should do a little
aside here because this right here is
newton
this right here is newton and if this is
newton's first law why do i have this
huge picture of this guy over here well
the reason is is because newton's first
law is really just a restatement of this
guy's law of inertia and this guy
another titan of civilization really
this is galileo galilei
galileo and he is the first person to
formulate the law of inertia and newton
just rephrased a little bit and packaged
with his other laws but he did many many
many other things so you really have to
give galileo credit for newton's first
law and so that's why i made him bigger
than here
but i was in the midst of a thought so
we understand if something is at rest
it's going to stay at rest unless
there's some force that acts on it and
in some definitions you'll see unless
there's some unbalanced force and the
reason that's why they say unbalanced is
because you could have two forces that
act on something and they might balance
out for example i could push on this
side of the rock with a certain amount
of force and if you push on this side of
the rock with the exact same amount of
force the rock won't move and the only
way that it would move if there's a lot
more force on one side than on the other
side so if you have an unbalanced force
so if you have a ton of if you and maybe
the rock is a bad analogy let's take ice
because ice is easy to move or ice on
ice so there's ice right here
and then i have another block of ice
sitting on top of that ice
so once again we're familiar with the
idea if there's no force acting on it
that ice won't move
but what happens if i have if i'm
pushing on the ice with a certain amount
of force on that side and you're pushing
on the ice on that side with the same
amount of force
the ice will still not move so this
right here this would be a balanced
force
a balanced force so the only way for the
ice to change its to change its
condition to change its restful
condition is if the force is unbalanced
so if we add a little bit of force on
this side so it over it oh it more than
compensates the force pushing it this
way then you're going to see the ice
block start to move start to really
accelerate in that direction but i think
this part is obvious this you know
something that's at rest will stay at
rest unless it's being acted on by an
unbalanced force what's less obvious is
the idea that something moving uniformly
straight forward which is another way of
saying something having a constant
velocity
constant velocity
what he's saying is that something that
has a constant velocity will continue to
have that constant velocity indefinitely
unless it is acted on by an unbalanced
force
and that's less intuitive because
everything in our human experience if i
even if i were to push if i were to push
this block of ice eventually it'll stop
it won't just keep going forever even
assuming that this ice field is
infinitely long that ice will eventually
stop or if i throw if i throw a
if i throw a tennis ball that tennis
ball will eventually stop even if even
if it doesn't even if it's it'll
eventually grind to a halt or if i roll
a bowling ball or if i
anything we've never seen at least in
our human experience it looks like
everything will eventually stop so this
is a very unintuitive thing to say that
something in motion will just keep going
in motion indefinitely everything in
human intuition says if you want
something to keep going into mo in
motion you have to keep putting more
force keep putting more energy into it
for it to keep going your car won't go
forever unless you keep unless the
engine keeps burning fuel and to drive
and and consuming energy so what are
they talking about well all of these
examples and i think this is actually a
pretty brilliant insight from for all of
these fellows is that there the all of
these things would have gone on forever
the ball would keep going forever this
ice block would be going on forever
except for the fact that there are
unbalanced forces acting on them to stop
them so in the case of ice even though
ice on ice doesn't have a lot of
friction there is some friction between
these two and so you have in this
situation the force of friction is going
to be acting against the direction of
the movement of the ice and friction
really comes from at a very at an atomic
level so if you have the actual
water molecules in a lattice structure
in the ice cube and then here are the
water molecules in the lattice structure
in the on the ice on the on the actual
kind of sea of ice that it's traveling
on
they do kind of bump and grind into each
other although they're both smooth
they're imperfections here they bump and
grind they generate a little bit of heat
and
they'll essentially
be be working against the movement so
there's a force of friction that's being
applied to here and that's why stopping
not only a force of friction you also
have some air resistance the ice block
is going to be bumping into all sorts of
air particles it might not be noticeable
at first but it's definitely going to
keep it from going on forever same thing
with the ball being tossed to the air
obviously at some point it hits the
ground because of gravity so that's one
force acting on it but even once it hits
the ground it doesn't keep rolling
forever once again because of the
friction
because of the frictions you know
especially if there's grass here the
grass is going to stop it from going and
even while it's in the air it's going to
slow down it's not going to have a
constant velocity because you have all
of these air particles that are going to
bump into it are going to bump into it
and exert and exert force to slow it
down so it was really brilliant about
these guys is that they could imagine a
reality
where you didn't have gravity where you
did not have air
slowing things down and they could
imagine that in that reality something
would just keep persisting in its motion
and the reason why galileo frankly was
probably good at thinking about that is
that he studied he studied the orbits of
planets
and he could or at least he's probably
theorized that hey maybe maybe there's
no air out there and that maybe that's
why these plants can just keep going
round and round in orbit and their their
their
i should say their speed because their
direction is changing but their speed
never slows down because there's no
there's nothing in the space to actually
slow down those planets so anyway
hopefully you found that as fascinating
as i do because on some level it's super
duper obvious but on a whole other level
it's completely not obvious especially
this moving uniformly straightforward
and just to make the point clear
if if if gravity disappeared and you had
no air and you threw or throw a ball
that ball literally would keep going in
that direction forever unless some other
unbalanced force acted to stop it and
another way to think about it another
way to think about and this is an
example that you might see in everyday
life is if i'm in a if i'm in a airplane
if i'm in an airplane that's going at a
completely constant velocity and there's
absolutely no turbulence in the airplane
so if i'm sitting in the airplane right
over here
and there it's going at a constant
velocity
so constant velocity
completely smooth no turbulence there's
really no way for me to tell whether
that airplane is moving without looking
out the window let's assuming that
there's no windows in that airplane it's
going at a constant velocity and there's
no turbulence and let's say and let's
say i have i i can't hear anything so i
can't even hear the engines there's no
way for me to sense that the plane is
moving because from my frame of
reference it looks completely identical
to if i was in it that same plane that
was resting on the ground and that's
another way to think about it that it's
actually very intuitive that they're
similar states moving at a constant
velocity
or being at rest you really can't tell
whether you're one or the other